last call for passengers as the uk ends
its travel corridor scheme
allowed by new coronavirus variants
emerging across the world
from monday all arrivals will have to
self-isolate
but some scientists warn stricter checks
are needed
to ensure people are complying i think
the system is very reliant on people
from the rules in place like australia
and new zealand
there are very tough restrictions when
you arrive you stay in a hotel generally
and you're monitoring that hotel in uk
it basically relies on on trust
so people declare their quarantining but
once once they arrive there wherever
they're staying
we have the idea if they're staying in
that accommodation or not if they're out
of the battery mixing with people
there are fears that a new or yet
unknown variant of the virus might be
resistant to vaccines
the government's main hope for a way out
of the pandemic
the peak of hospital admissions is
approaching according to england's chief
medical officer
but deaths will keep on climbing the
peak of deaths i fear is
in the future the peak of
hospitalizations in some parts of the
country
uh maybe around about now and come
beginning to come off the
very very top but at an incredibly high
rate and i cannot stress that enough
the strain on hospitals has led the
scottish government to tighten
restrictions from saturday including a
ban on collecting takeaways from inside
restaurants
but some have questioned the impact
these measures can have
there's definitely things that have come
through and made a lot of sense i'm not
really sure this one does in particular
we've got one bar operating as a
takeaway venue at the moment
and that's doing probably about a tenth
of what it would normally do in a normal
given week
and that's obviously about to reduce a
little bit more with the extra
restrictions as the second wave batters
the uk
authorities say things will likely
improve in the spring
but any restrictions would be lifted
gradually
milena veselinovich sky news